hi I'm the director Francis Lawrence I'm
here today to break down a scene from
The Hunger Games the ballot of song
birds and
snakes dress
4 3 dress up
one
run so what we have here is the very
beginning of the 10th annual Hunger Game
games you know every time uh I approach
the beginning of the games I want it to
feel emotionally different and one of
the fun things here is the games are
very rudimentary we don't have any fancy
elevators or anything like that anymore
um and what I really enjoy is the idea
that everybody's getting walked out at
gunpoint by peacekeepers some people
getting dragged out some people getting
shoved out and they all have to sort of
stand on their little
circles uh and we have a also a very
rudimentary almost half broken speaker
system hearing lucky flickerman doing
the countdown down to the beginning of
the games and then a very rudimentary
buzzer as well that sort of kicks
everything off for the 10th annual
Hunger Games uh because we're seeing the
early early days of the arena and the
games themselves we needed something
that felt almost Coliseum like almost
like a a place you would find in Rome
and my production designer and I uh
searched uh ulie Hanish the production
designer searched around the world and
found a fantastic Arena called
Centennial Hall in VW Poland and luckily
we were able to secure it for about 6
weeks it was the very beginning of our
schedule we uh got to shoot there um
right away and put our games in and they
let us do a lot we had to add a bunch of
rubel a bunch of dust a bunch of dirt we
also did some digital augmentation to
the walls there's a big sequence early
on with explosions that damages the the
the structure this is the first time um
in any of the stories and any of the
games where because of explosions the
landscape of the games have changed and
so when you see the rubble that's all
because of these explosions that have
now blown holes into the floor giving
access down to tunnels or access into
sort of air vents that's put a big pile
of rubble in the center which you can
tell is probably the beginning for the
idea of the Cornucopia that's set in the
center of the games after
this what are you doing
frun
[Music]
at this point of the movie there's a
sequence that happens the night before
the games uh where Cory lanus has come
up with a plan he's seen how the
landscape of the Arena has changed and
he's gone to visit her in the zoo where
she's being held captive before the
games and he tells her a plan to go run
down into the tunnels that are
underneath the arena and to go hide and
not to go with anybody not to wait for
anybody not to go for any weapons um but
we do get a sense that Lucy has made
friends with one of the tributes and the
tribute from also from District 12 and
they want to protect each other and he's
gotten
increasingly more sickly from some
strange wound he has on his neck and she
wants to take care of him um so when the
gamees start instead of her running to
the spot that snow wanted to run to go
and hide she goes to try to find her
District partner so she can try to help
him the best that she can which of
course puts her in danger um from some
of the stronger tributes like Reaper and
coral one of the sort of core aspects of
the movie is the relationship between
snow young snow and Lucy Gray
and Tom and Rachel have great chemistry
which is fantastic but it was really fun
to sort of play with the relationship
and the Mystery of the relationship
because the two have this kind of mutual
need for each other you know Tom wants
her to listen to him and to win because
if she does he does she obviously needs
him he's her Mentor she needs him to try
to win because that way she actually
survives so there's this m Mutual need
but there's always a bit of a mystery of
whether or not their feelings for each
other are
[Applause]
true for a sequence like this we spend a
long time choreographing it I work with
my stunt coordinator Scot AA uh very
very closely and what typically we'll do
is we'll take the sort of Beats that are
important for the story and we'll kind
of map that all out out and then we'll
draw diagrams of what we think the arena
is going to look like and where we want
tributes to be we also have a sort of
another list of we have to know which
tributes are actually supposed to die in
the sequence um and then we kind of send
Scott off with a bunch of stunt people
to start to choreograph and one of the
things that I also wanted to do was for
the most part to have shots link up and
last for long periods of time and
usually also very focused on Lucy Gray
so he would choreograph some of the
fighting and the battles and what
everybody's doing because you have close
to 24 tributes in this Arena all sort of
vying for you know for weapons and
fighting with one another he'll
choreograph all that and we'll start to
design the kind of camera moves around
that once we lock in on all the story
beats and what the fighting is all like
and who's dying and where they end up
and and get the story right we then
bring the actors in we train them in the
sequence almost like learning a dance
and then we bring our camera operator in
and the cinematographer in and we start
to choreograph the camera moves and this
is all done on a stage not even on set
yet not with the big cameras but even
with just like iPhones and things like
that so that we have everything
perfectly planned out so that on the day
when we're there and everybody's in
costume and hair and makeup and we've
got all the rubble around and you know
the set pieces we can move really
efficiently through the
sequence
what's interesting about this um and
this all comes from the book and from
Suzanne is that you know uh Lucy gray
who is the female tribute from District
12 often people compare her to Katniss
who was also the female tribute from 12
um they are very different people what
they share in common is that they're
both really intelligent and they're both
survivors it's how they do their
different things that are that are very
very different you know Lucy gray is a
performer she's an extrovert she uses
charm she knows how to manipulate she
can flirt um and she's very very smart
and quite cunning whereas Katniss is a
little more sort of introverted quiet
introspective she's a hunter she's more
capable with weapons um so very very
distinctly different kinds of characters
choosing Rachel she was my first choice
to to play Lucy gray um I had seen her
in Westside Story she's a very very
talented actor um I knew that she could
sort of play all the different facets
that we needed for for Lucy gray um
there's also music as a big element in
this movie and and Rachel has an amazing
amazing voice uh which made the songs
fantastic uh but you know what I really
like is that Rachel as an actor and lcy
gray specifically is not really built to
be an AR in an arena and fighting and so
I like that sort of Fish Out of Water
feel that she and especially in this
kind of rainbow dress that's so specific
to her kind of stands out um in this
Arena filled with you know dirt and dust
and and Rubble you know the dress for
Lucy gray is an iconic piece of the
story you know this was something that
was described in the book that was
written by Suzanne Collins and became an
iconic piece for Lucy gray and a very
important part of the story Trish and I
started talking about it and started
talking about you know how the dress has
been passed down it was her mother's
it's passed down to her um Trish wanted
to design something that felt authentic
to the location of District 12 to the
idea that she's part of the sort of
traveling troop of musicians and
performers there's a slight can can
element to it but Al also this kind of
West Virginia the hollows of West
Virginia sort of feel to it but then
Trish also knew that we were going to be
doing a lot of different things she was
going to have to run around she was
going to have to to roll around in the
dirt she was going to have to be able to
move freely so a lot of the sort of
practical design of the dress Trish had
to be very very smart with so that it
would work in sequences like
this to go come on get out of here we
got to go we got to
[Music]
go